[upbeat, funky music]
♪ ♪
- This is delicious,
Mrs. Cramblin.
- I know it's terrible, honey,
but thank you.
- No, he said it was delicious.
- Oh, Trevor, do you wanna
join us for Sunday dinner?
- [sucks teeth] No can do.
- Trevor, your mother
invited you to sit down.
Sit down.
- Hey, uh, Jerry,
why don't--why don't you
eat my ass?
- Rude.
- What is he still doing
in the house?
I thought he moved
into the house
with, like, 15 of his friends.
- It didn't work out.
They turned out all
to be backstabbers and liars.
All 15 of them.
They were nasty to him.
- Boy needs a job.
- Jerry.
- He got fired from Le Shish?
- My dad got him that job.
- It wasn't his fault.
They were nasty to him.
They wouldn't let him choose
what time he came in.
- So he just didn't show up,
is what you're saying?
- Honestly, he has to sleep in
or he'll lose his voice.
Besides, he doesn't have time
for a job.
He's very busy with Rochu.
- What is Rochu?
- Rochu is an Ultra Beast
Trevor created.
Look at the beautiful
pictures he makes.
- Mom, don't put that
on the fridge!
- The details are fantastic,
Chrissy.
Now, Rochu is the king
of the Banglo people.
And he defeated Malgor
in the Battle of Light.
- Oh.
- He's a Lich Priest.
Uh--is that how
you say it, Jerry?
Am I--Lich--Lich Priest?
- I don't freakin' know.
It's a bunch of cartoons
with their dicks out.
- Jerry!
- They are, Sue.
Some artist.
Asked him to draw
a picture of his mother and me
in Wings jerseys,
he gives me a freakin'
drippin' hog.
- Chrissy, you should see
the details on that hog.
It's as if he's seen it.
Down...to...the...veins.
- ♪ Next time ♪